you know what this is it this is I
figured it out all that other new
[ __ ] doesn't have this [ __ ]
Island you know what it's cuz we didn't
have the face thing that's what wasn't
it you miss my face didn't you look at
me I'm in the I'm in the corner yeah hey
what's going on YouTube I know I've been
experimenting with the experiment will
turn I've been experimenting with all
this new [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] like it
I'm doing going back to my original
rants in the way that I do it maybe in
this new setting who knows I know it's
been like a hard transition for you guys
because you guys know watching this
channel do a lot of weird things and a
lot of you hated it and I understand -
and you guys are completely entitled to
your opinions I just wanted to try
something new but we going back to those
original brands like and some of you
really dig as someone who did it mmm I
get it I gotta agree with like a good
portion of you it didn't have that Damon
so you know what I mean it's not even a
[ __ ] word so as you guys already
noticed on this video it's gonna be a
heart-to-heart talk and I'm gonna give
you guys an opportunity to do something
with me so a while back if you guys know
these dudes Jesse and Kong from simple
pickup they reach out to me to to work
on a product and also a project with
them now if you guys haven't seen simple
pickup they're pretty [ __ ] legit they
got like 2.6 million followers and a
whole bunch of other stuff that they're
doing I absolutely love these dudes
they're my boys it follows the girl I
probably [ __ ] them that's [ __ ] weird
so anyways they started this platform
called a jump cut Academy and basically
what jump cut Academy is it I'm not
gonna give you guys [ __ ] it teaches
you how to be a [ __ ] dope ass
youtuber now who the [ __ ] is this did
you just but you do but diarrhea what
can you get you get me food can you get
me yeah let me give me a sausage Egg
McMuffin and also a hug thank you but
what the [ __ ] was I talking about
oh yeah so we're talking about jump cut
Academy and just to cut the [ __ ] it
teaches you how to [ __ ] be a youtuber
and I know that sounds [ __ ] dumb and
you guys might not understand this
concept but listen it's just give me a
[ __ ] second to explain this to you
I'm gonna be teaching an exclusive
course on their jump cut Academy on how
to be a [ __ ] dope
opinionated vlogger that's right a
[ __ ] opinionated vlogger with real
thoughts and ideas and I'm gonna teach
you guys how to pop off on they should
have make a [ __ ] career out of this so
if you guys can tell like you know and
you guys know me to like I don't put
[ __ ] on my [ __ ] channel that I don't
believe in so a lot of you guys don't
know this about me but I've been doing
stand-up comedy or I tend to do stand-up
comedy since I was like 16 years old and
that was a point in my life where I'm
gonna just give you the short truncated
version whoo College work I [ __ ]
hated everything like I lose [ __ ] I was
working like so many jobs trying to
figure out what I was supposed to do
really trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] am I supposed to do now I want you
to think about that for a second you
know it got to a point for me where look
I got it like static comedy wasn't one
of those things that you know you either
can be really successful at it or your
life can just go to the [ __ ] [ __ ]
but I was willing to [ __ ] risk that
and you know my family relationship
wasn't doing too well because you know
I'm a Korean American kid that wants to
be a stand-up comedian like how many
Korean parents do you know that when you
at when you [ __ ] tell them hey Dad I
want to be a stand-up comedian your
dad's gonna come back and be like I was
so proud of you a cassock you know it
was it was it was a difficult road and I
remember what YouTube did for me it
allowed me at that time I was working so
many [ __ ] jobs just to like pursue
what I wanted to do to bring my comedy
out there to people without you know
killing me and putting it on a platform
we're more than just a small crowd of
people can see it and it really changed
my [ __ ] life and I got to tell you
something like when I first started
doing YouTube I used to like lightweight
hate on it because I was like you know
I'm a real stand-up comedian but I fail
to realize is is that [ __ ] all that
negativity what was the main reason why
you became who you are today or why do
you even wanted to do stand-up comedy
and the main reason was to make people
laugh and at the end of the day you know
[ __ ] all this emotional [ __ ] cuz I'm
about to get [ __ ] teary-eyed you know
I owe it all to YouTube and I owe it all
to my channel and it really opened up my
eyes to a world that I really didn't
know about so going back into like Java
code Academy and what I want you guys to
take away from this is that yeah it's
it's a course that you that utilize our
to be a part of that if you guys want to
this is not something that I'm
pressuring you to do there are a few of
you out there right now but then look at
yourself and you're like I want to be a
youtuber I want to do what this guy does
I want to do what that guy does I mean
it doesn't even have to be vlogging per
se you can do it but there's a lot of
you guys out there who don't know how to
and you think that you can't do it
because you don't have the proper tools
you don't have the right training well
guess what I'm gonna give that to you
and I'm gonna tell you this right now
and I'm saying this from the bottom of
my [ __ ] heart because I've seen this
course and I've seen the people that are
also a part of this and by the way it's
not just me that's gonna be teaching you
how to be a part of YouTube and to be
[ __ ] successful at it to get millions
and millions of subscribers there's a
bunch of other [ __ ] high profile
youtubers that are part of this this is
the best platform for that [ __ ]
everything else that you heard this is
the best one I kid you not so before we
even jump in there just ask yourself
this question like is this what you want
so let me cut all the [ __ ] and let's
get into how you guys can sign up for
jump cut Academy number one I definitely
had to negotiate a price for you guys so
if you guys get it today that's right
it's gonna be 50% off of what you get it
for at the end of the week the deals
gonna be running for seven days so
please please please make sure that you
get on this real quick cuz it's gonna be
gone and that leaks gonna be below and
just in case or some of you out there
that thinks is a scam there is a 30-day
money-back guarantee straight up your
[ __ ] money back so you could try it
out for 30 days and I mentioned this
before but you're getting access not to
only my belonging series but everybody
else to like any type of like you to
[ __ ] that you're thinking about getting
a part of we have online courses for
that it's not like a typical online
course it's really in debt really
personal like we're giving you all of
the [ __ ] that we've accumulated for like
the past five or ten years so if you
aren't like a hundred and million four
thousand percent like into this then you
don't have to be a part of it like
there's a 30-day money-back guarantee
just just give it a go like if this is
something that you want try it out it's
not gonna hurt you right so once again
I'm gonna be on this course make sure
you guys click my link and purchase that
through there and let me know if you
love it seriously for those of you who
are gonna hop on this let me know if you
absolutely love it because I saw the
product and I [ __ ] loved it and I
think it's the amount of knowledge
that's given on these courses is unreal
if I had this when I started out
it would've made my life ten times
easier seriously if you guys want to be
a part of this YouTube community you
don't know where to start and you want
to really kick it off a lot faster than
most other people are going to hop on
this let me know what you think
like I'm not you know I'm not scared I'm
pissed I'm not disabling comments and a
thumbs down or whatever like well
seriously see what's up so once again
I'm not shoving this down your throat
I'm putting it out there but if you want
to be a part of this click that link and
hop on that [ __ ] real quick me and you
we family do I'll see y'all next time
try not to suck too many dicks unless
you want to and that's your lifestyle or
you're around are you offering to be